top house Republican says Russia's goal
is to create chaos during the upcoming
midterm elections how to prevent that is
a major talking point tonight following
a high-level briefing from some of the
country's top intelligence officials but
correspondent Peter Doocy tells us from
Capitol Hill apparently many in Congress
are not that interested in a room
beneath the Capitol this morning the
intel chiefs who came to deliver a
classified briefing about election
interference that every House member was
invited to shared those secrets with a
lot of empty seats I would say we had a
good 40 or so members that attended
that's 40 or so out of 428 members
serving right now one theory Congress
didn't want to commute an hour early
well wasn't 8 o'clock still Homeland
Security Committee Chairman Mike McCall
was surprised that so many lawmakers who
talk about election interference on the
stump blew off the Director of National
Intelligence FBI director and DHS
secretary the Democrats have made this
such a big issue and have asked for this
briefing for a long time and we finally
scheduled it that's classified and you
know 30 members show up every member of
Congress that isn't retiring is up for
re-election in the midterms but none are
known to be in the crosshairs of foreign
meddlers right now we have no intel that
there's a particular race of interest
secretary Neilson also explained that in
addition to Russia China and Iran are
considered threats to election integrity
but that the kind of interference the
Intel community is worried about in 2018
is the same kind detected in 2016 where
ballots aren't changed but social media
is manipulated to cause chaos I think we
remain concerned certainly on the
foreign influence side I mean we've seen
that continually details like that did
not dazzle the Democrats who did attend
I didn't hear one bit of classified
information and there was nothing that I
couldn't have read in USA Today that
that was revealed so so the fact that
there was a low attendance it probably
doesn't matter
this was the rare russia-related event
on Capitol Hill that happened behind
closed doors so it's going to be very
interesting to see if
hundreds of lawmakers who decided they
didn't want the classified update today
decide to show up to the next Russia
hearing where the cameras are rolling
the whole time
Brett Peter moments ago the House passed
legislation to ease banking rules
essentially a reform of the dodd-frank
law what do we know about the bill
that's actually now heading to the
President's desk it's making life easier
for smaller banks in this country after
the financial crisis with the dodd-frank
regulations the feds put the strictest
regulations on banks that were worth
fifty billion dollars or more they said
those banks are too big to fail they
must be regulated but now too big to
fail is bigger 250 billion dollars five
times that size is now the
too-big-to-fail threshold that means
that a lot of smaller banks are going to
have a lot fewer regulations this does
not repeal dodd-frank but it does roll
back a lot of important regulations and
it is the rare measure that very easily
cleared the Senate and the house breath
Peter Doocy live on the hill Peter thank
you